my dream is to be a success I hear this
all the time for a lot of entrepreneurs
or want to be entrepreneurs and it's
great to want to be successful but
everybody wants to be successful if you
want to be successful you have to make
it more tangible you got to tell me what
that looks like you have to believe that
it's possible and you got to do
something every day to make that
business happen and get closer to your
dream I got a question from one of my
readers thousands on my newsletter list
according to say I'm a student
entrepreneur I had a business it failed
I don't know where to begin I don't have
any assets my dream is to be a
successful entrepreneur I hope you can
give me a direction Evan thank you so
frozen and for everybody else who has
that same goal you got to make that more
tangible just to be successes and enough
you can't just dream to be a success you
got to have something in plant in place
where you need a plan what do you want
to become what a success look like for
you everybody wants to be successful the
more tangible you can make it the more
you can break it down and the
step-by-step the easier it's going to be
for you to go and achieve it and the
fast you're going to get to your goal
there's a big difference between
dreamers and achievers a lot of people
have dreams a lot of people want to go
out and accomplish something they dream
that they can go on vacation they dream
that they can visit every country in the
world the dream they can have a
successful business they dream the dream
the dream they hope they hope they hope
and they don't do anything to take
action entrepreneurs are action takers
okay I don't have any major dreams if I
want something I go and I start doing it
and then it happens I remember when I
was thinking about building my dream
house I got the idea I want to build my
dream house I started looking browsing
for the place to build I built my house
from scratch and as soon as I started
that process it had to happen I couldn't
stop if I get an idea in my head it just
starts to happen i start to work on it I
don't have things that I say on five
years i'm going to do this if I want
something I go after and I start
achieving it right now small steps but
go after still building momentum and
that momentum will lead to change if you
want something you go out and start
doing something right now you want to
start a business start a business find
something you're passionate about find
something that will help people and
start doing something right now don't
wait to say in five years I want to do
this that's not a true entrepreneur if
you want something you go out and you
start to achieve it so with my house I
went out I went with a real estate agent
I started looking for properties I
happened to find a great property i
bought it i started building i built a
great house and then eventually sold it
because i discover didn't want a huge
house but didn't matter because it was
in my head that I wanted that to happen
so I started making that happen you have
a vision for something you got to get
crystal clear in what you want and then
the world will align itself to help you
achieve that you start telling people
what you want to look for ways to help
you most people are wandering aimlessly
you tell somebody want to be a
successful entrepreneur what can they do
with that they can help you you got to
be specific you got to let people know
what it is that you're looking for even
if you've never done it before even it's
very scary even if you have no idea how
you're going to go out and accomplish it
you need to get specific on what your
goal is start reaching out to people
start telling people what you're doing
and take steps every day to move closer
to accomplishing it and you'll learn and
you'll make mistakes but you're gaining
momentum and what you did yesterday and
the day before and the day before we'll
all help you today they get closer to
your goal so that's the most important
piece of advice that I can give you stop
being a dreamer start being an action
taker get specific and start taking
action believe those are you watching
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below it always takes going to do
more for you and I love to hear what you
think leave a comment underneath I love
seemed to come in every day when I'm
eating my lentils for breakfast i watch
the comments I respond to you guys it
makes my day keeps me going so please
leave a comment underneath and you have
a question leave it in a comment section
below I make a video response thank you
so much
I'll see you soon